bonjour tout le monde
mes chers collègues nous sommes
aujourd'hui réunis dans le cadre de
notre commission enquête pour l'audition
de Monsieur Pascal regard directeur
général de la SACD accompagné Monsieur
Patrick Road qui est secrétaire général
de l'organisme donc la Société des
Auteurs et Compositeurs Dramatiques
monsieur Roger vous présente l'audition
Judy la fin est filmé capté mais donc
c'est pour pour replacer un peu tout le
monde dans son contexte après avoir
débuté en créant une troupe de thé à
vous et présider différentes fonctions
au sein d'organismes professionnels du
monde audiovisuel et cinématographique
depuis 2004 vous dirigez la SACD fondée
comme chacun sait par beau marché donc
en 1777 et elle est la plus ancienne des
sociétés françaises de gestion
collective de droits d'auteur là ça
c'est des protège perçoit et réparties
des droits de près de 60 000 hauteurs
membres dans les domaines du spectacle
vivant de l'audiovisuel du cinéma
et du web ses droits d'auteurs se sont
élevés à plus de 250 millions d'euros en
2022 ce qui était un chiffre record nous
indiquant la montée en puissance des
plateformes peut apporter de nouvelles
ressources aux auteurs du secteur
audiovisuel du spectacle vivant en
offrant des moyens de diffusion mais
encore faut-il que ces plateformes c'est
un débat qui commence presque à être
anciens respecte les droits d'auteur
votre société a signé en décembre 2022
un accord avec le groupe meta portant
sur l'utilisation du répertoire de la
SACD les utilisateurs de Facebook et
d'Instagram peuvent donc regarder et
partager librement les oeuvres du
répertoire et je dirais légalement
surtout de la SACD et les hauteurs de
ces auteurs de ses œuvres sont rémunérés
en conséquence
si un accord avec méta a été passé il
semblerait qu'aucun contrat similaire
n'a été conclu pour l'heure avec Tik Tok
la SSD envisagerait même d'assigner
l'entreprise mais vous en direz plus
pour non respect du droit d'auteur et
vous nous direz ce qui nous intéresse
notamment aujourd'hui ou on sent vos
relations avec cette entreprise et vous
nous donnerez vos propositions pour
assurer une application effective du
droit d'auteur sur TikTok je ne dois
vous rappeler que cette audition est
captée retransmise en direct sur le site
du Sénat et avant de vous laisser la
parole à l'un et à l'autre comme vous le
souhaiterez pour un exposé linéaire
d'une quinzaine de minutes si ça vous
convient ainsi je dois procéder au
formalité d'usage pour les commissions
d'enquête et vous rappelez qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête et passible des peines prévues
aux articles 434 13 434 et 434 15 du
code pénal et je vous invite à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité en levant la main droite et en
disant je le jure
merci bien donc on est là aujourd'hui
avec notre collègue Pierre ouzulias et
bien évidemment le rapporteur
et Cédric Perrin et que j'allais citer
je faisais dans l'ordre et les
administrateurs et un peu de public donc
voilà on vous écoute pour l'exposé
linéaire et puis nous aurons quelques
questions après vous poser donc merci de
nous accueillir pour cette audition nous
avons souhaité vous parler parce que
les sujets TikTok ont été abordés sont
des sujets de données personnelles un
énorme sujet qui est actuellement traité
par la CNIL irlandaise qui est
compétente puisque le siège de Tik Tok
est en Irlande il est rare d'ailleurs
que le siège des grandes sociétés
Internet soit en France en Italie ou en
Allemagne mais passons et
le sujet dont nous voulons aborder
aujourd'hui c'est celui du droit
d'auteur
comme vous l'avez rappelé président la
SSD qui est la plus ancienne société
d'auteur pas seulement de France mais du
monde parce que vos marchés en réalité
inventé le droit d'auteur nous avons
traité avec l'ensemble des plateformes
la première avec laquelle nous avons
traité je crois que c'était en 2010
c'était YouTube et on a passé un accord
c'est bien passé il y a eu des
négociations la seule chose c'est qu'à
l'époque nous n'avions pas le droit de
dire que nous respections les principes
de beau marché c'est à dire la
rémunération proportionnelle maintenant
ça c'est de la communication parce que
quand vous signez un accord en France et
que ce sont des sociétés qui sont
établies dans toute l'Europe même le
monde entier elles aiment pas que sa
fâche sa fasse tache d'huile par rapport
à ce qu'elles peuvent signer dans dans
d'autres pays qui n'ont pas forcément
une législation aussi protectrice que la
France même si maintenant le droit
d'auteur est quasiment complètement
harmonisé à l'échelle européenne par des
directives qui ont élevé le niveau de
protection et en particulier la nouvelle
directive de 2018 droit d'auteur qui a
ensuite été transposée par ordonnance
par le gouvernement français avec une
transposition que le premier ministre
Jean Castex a évolue et qui s'est
réalisé ambitieuse voilà donc on a une
protection du droit d'auteur en France
non seulement du droit rémunération mais
du droit moral
à un niveau qui n'a jamais été aussi
élevé
après il y a les principes dans la loi
et puis il y a les applications
concrètes donc notre première
négociation avec les plateformes ça a
été YouTube ensuite on a eu des
négociations le suivant qui est arrivé
c'est Netflix ça c'est très très bien
passé avec Netflix s'ils étaient venus
nous voir avant même de démarrer leurs
opérations sur le territoire français et
on a signé un accord je pense trois
quatre mois après
leur mise en oeuvre sur sur notre dans
notre pays et c'est un accord que nous
considérons comme satisfaisant alors
avec Netflix il y a eu des fantasmes il
respecte pas le droit d'auteur et tout
je peux dire que c'est faux il le
respecte ensuite on a eu des
négociations avec Amazon avec Disney
qui sont des plateformes sensiblement du
même style que Netflix même si ils ont
moins d'oeuvres audiovisuelles que
Netflix et on a maintenant des
discussions on a eu des discussions avec
qui elle est une plateforme est
différente parce que c'est une site
communautaire sensiblement différent des
sites qui font de la diffusion
finalement relativement classique et on
a abouti un accord avec
meta à la suite de discussion qu'on
durée je crois à peu près deux ans
un an et demi mais c'est des discussions
bien sûr qui sont compliquées parce que
avec les sociétés américaines ceux qui
sont en France sont pas forcément tous
les pouvoirs et doivent référer à des
personnes qui sont au-dessus d'eux et
qui ne connaissent pas forcément
parfaitement les principes d'auteur à la
française et à l'européenne
donc voilà les les accords qu'on a passé
alors avec TikTok là c'est complètement
différent on est dans une situation
totalement inédite parce que je ne sais
pas si vous le savez mais avant de
commencer les négociations normalement
on signe un accord de confidentialité et
on s'engage à ne pas parler des
négociations c'est-à-dire des sujets de
la négociation et des montants qui
peuvent être en jeu or ce que nous a
demandé Tic-Toc elle est bien au-delà de
ça ils nous ont demandé de ne même pas
pouvoir dire à notre conseil
d'administration donc aux auteurs qui
nous ont mandatés que nous étions en
discussion avec eux
et donc ce genre de ce qui fait qu'on
n'a pas pu aboutir à la signature d'un
accord de confidentialité et que on
s'est engagé dans des négociations par
l'intermédiaire d'avocat ce qui garantit
aussi la confidentialité mais c'est un
processus très compliqué les la première
rencontre que nous avons vraiment avec
TikTok dadiana c'était avec
Eric Garandeau qui agit sur le
territoire français je vous expliquerai
ce qu'il fait après ce qui n'est pas
opérationnel pour TikTok il achète de
l'influence qui est pas tout à fait la
même chose bon et on lui avait dit qu'il
y avait un gros problème droit d'auteur
problème de droit d'auteur qu'il connaît
parfaitement puisque il avait été le
conseiller du président Nicolas Sarkozy
qui est président qui a énormément
défendu le droit d'auteur et ensuite on
s'est aperçu que rien n'avançait dans
les discussions et que ça ne progressait
pas donc pour le moment
on a aucun accord avec la plateforme et
le constat qu'on a pu faire c'est que il
se constat a été fait par l'ALPA
d'ailleurs je vous le fournirai le
constat de l'ALPA comme ça vous aurez
une vue assez exhaustive de ce qui se
passe sur TikTok constate à une valeur
puisqu'il est fait par des agents
assermentaires elle passe et
l'association de lutte contre la
piraterie audiovisuelle qui est présidée
par Nicolas Seydoux et qui regroupe
l'ensemble des ayants droits français et
des entreprises américaines et ce
constat c'est qu'il y a énormément
d'oeuvre du répertoire de la SSD notre
répertoire c'est toute la fiction
audiovisuelle le cinéma l'animation et
puis le spectacle vivant
l'humour dans les dans le système de
captation qui peuvent être repris et
donc il y a énormément d'oeuvres de SACD
vous le verrez dans en lisant le constat
et donc ces œuvres pour le on ne peut
pas rémunérer leurs auteurs puisque nous
n'avons pas d'accord avec Tik Tok alors
ce que nous pouvons faire c'est
évidemment assigner Tic-Toc mais c'est
quelque chose que l'on a recours
au dernier moment parce que si vous
assignez vous rentrez dans le cours et
le parcours assez long de la justice
française
et avec toute quand vous avez en face de
vous des sociétés particulières qui ont
des gros moyens ça peut être assez
compliqué donc nous on préfère passer
des accords avoir des partenariats comme
on l'a avec toutes les plateformes soft
TikTok et parce qu'ensuite on a en plus
besoin que ces plateformes nous
fournissent un certain nombre de données
pour pouvoir rémunérer les ayants droits
dont les œuvres sont diffusées donc
voilà voilà où nous en sommes pour le
pour le moment
alors ce qui nous a choqué c'est que
d'un côté
le droit d'auteur n'est pas respecté ça
n'avance pas il y a même pas de
discussions véritable qui sont engagées
peut-être qu'il y en aura après cette
audition parce que ils vont sûrement Tik
Tok écouter l'audition et peut-être
faire un peu plus attention et que de
l'autre côté vous avez une entreprise
qui va chercher l'influence culturelle
ils ont nommé pour cela l'ancien
président du Centre national de la
cinématographie
du président Nicolas Sarkozy pour la
culture et la communication et qui
incarne échec avec lequel il achète les
institutions culturelles
là par exemple un partenariat avec le
Festival de Cannes nous avons écrit au
Festival de Cannes pour leur dire mais
pourquoi vous avez pour partenaire une
entreprise qui fait de la piraterie
audiovisuelle puisqu'ils ont pas
d'accord on nous a répondu on a besoin
d'argent
bon je trouve pas ça terrible comme
réponse ensuite on voit qu'il y a un
partenariat avec le Louvre récemment il
y a un partenariat avec le Salon du
livre enfin il y a toute une série
d'opérations
d'influence qui vise à montrer que Tik
Tok a un rôle à jouer dans le domaine de
la culture alors même que il ne respecte
pas ce qui est fondamental et sur lequel
la France a beaucoup agi qui est le
droit d'auteur donc on est dans une
logique d'obstruction
autre chose
la liste donc cette liste des
partenariats je vais quand même vous la
revenez salon du livre Le Louvre Réunion
des musées nationaux école nationale
supérieure Louis Lumière Forum des
Images enfin vous pouvez vous-même
peut-être faire la liste l'année
dernière il y avait d'ailleurs un
festival Tik Tok de court-métrages qui
était présidé le jury était
présidenté puis des revenus parce que il
a dénoncé à l'époque des pressions qui
avaient été faites sur lui dans le choix
des gagnants donc il y avait lui deux
personnes du jury qui avaient
démissionné ensuite ils ont discuté avec
Tik Tok ils sont revenus donc ce qui
nous choque c'est que en gros nos
institutions culturelles
pour des raisons financières que des
raisons financières associe leur nom à
une entreprise qui ne respecte
aucunement une des valeurs capitales de
notre pays en matière de culture c'est
le respect du droit d'auteur voilà ce
qu'on avait à dire devant vous
ce matin et cet après-midi
mais certainement vous permettez juste
sur le droit d'auteur parce qu'à la
beaucoup insisté sur le évidemment le
droit rémunération proportionnel des
auteurs qui intègrement important mais
il y a une deuxième composante de droits
d'auteur qui est le respect du droit
moral et l'intégrité de l'oeuvre et sur
la plateforme TiK ToK on a de nombreux
auteurs et autrices qui nous indiquent
leurs œuvres sans leur accord sont
coupés en petits morceaux en short
et du coup ça dénature complètement
le droit moral de ces auteurs parfois
s'agissant de spectacle d'humoriste vous
avez les spectacles où vous voyez
l'humoriste sur scène et la voix est
masquée et c'est la voix d'un tiktoker
qui se substitue à celle de l'humoriste
ou l'inverse parfois c'est la voix d'un
humoriste connu que tout le monde peut
reconnaître et c'est un tiktoker qui se
filme en train de d'adopter une
gestuelle proche ou ou pas proche
d'ailleurs de celle de l'hum donc il y a
cette double dimension de remoral droit
rémunération proportionnelle je voulais
juste revenir sur le Pascal regarde
mentionné la durée des négociations
qu'on a eu avec meta lors de 18 mois ce
que je voulais dire c'est ça peut
apparaître long mais on sait d'emblée
mis d'accord avec méta des la
transposition en droit français de la
directive droit d'auteur sur le fait que
à l'issue de ces négociations puisque
dès le début il y avait un accord de
principe de méta pour conclure un accord
avec nous on a passé ces 18 mois pour se
mettre d'accord sur le prix et la nature
des informations qu'ils allaient nous
nous communiquer mais dès le début il
était convenu que cet accord
rétroagirait au mois de mai 2021 date de
la transposition alors à date comme
Pascal voulait dit sur TiK ToK on a même
pas de discussions donc on arrive on a
juste eu des discussions sur cet accord
de confidentialité il y a un point parce
qu'elle n'a pas mentionné mais dans les
demandes de Tik Tok sur voilà je voulais
dire
j'étais accusé de dénigrer Tik Tok parce
que j'avais retweeté la déclaration du
Président de la République qui
critiquait Tik Tok pour son influence
néfaste sur les adolescents voilà et je
vous conseille aussi de lire le
règlement de Tik Tok à destination des
tiktokers c'est à dire ceux qui qui
bénéficient de remonter de recettes
parce qu'ils ont des oeuvres qui sont
diffusées sur Tik Tok et ils les ont
c'est remontés en tant que producteur de
lèvres et il y a un moyen très simple
pour TikTok de faire respecter enfin de
censurer l'expression de ces tiktokers
c'est que ilise l'oeuvre il la retire
pas mais ils enlèvent toute publicité ce
qui fait que l'oeuvre ne rapporte plus
rien à celui qui l'a mis en
scène enfin en diffusion sur sur la
plateforme et donc c'est c'est très
intéressant de lire cette cette
directive de Tik Tok qui s'applique à
tous les tiktokers et qui est de
respecter de pas dénigrer enfin c'est
quand même des une atteintes en fait à
la liberté d'expression et la liberté de
création c'est à dire si je diffuse sur
TikTok j'ai pas le droit de dire du mal
de TikTok si je dis du mal de TiK ToK on
m'enlève les ressources que je peux
avoir par la publicité qui est mise sur
à côté ou avant le programme que que je
vais diffuser donc c'est c'est on est
quand même dans un monde
qui veut restreindre la liberté
d'expression en ce qui me concerne je
n'avais jamais fait l'objet de menaces
pourtant j'ai tweeté contre des gens
très connus je le dis mais je n'avais
fait jamais fait de menaces de cette
nature voilà et mais ça s'adressait
d'ailleurs plus au président de la
République à moi-même je pense
commencer par les questions de monsieur
le rapporteur est-ce que vous autorisez
une demande de précision par rapport à
ce qui vient d'être dit pour être sûr
que d'avoir bien compris j'imagine ce
directeur général que vous avez comment
dire pour pouvoir mener enfin je me mène
je me mets à la place d'un je me mets
dans les mêmes configurations dans un
conseil municipal ou une collectivité
pour pouvoir mener des négociations ou
ester en justice ou que sais-je on peut
avoir une délégation assez large mais
par contre il faut rendre compte de
temps à autre à son assemblée des
libérantes à son conseil vous nous avez
expliqué que on peut avoir des
négociations du fait du secret des
affaires au cours desquels on s'engage à
ne pas rendre public l'état des
négociations les difficultés ou
l'avancement et les questions de montant
qui peut se comprendre mais là ce qu'on
vous demande c'est de ne pas dire aux
gens dont vous avez délégation que vous
représentez ou pour le compte desquels
vous agissez de ne pas dire que vous
êtes en négociation avec Tik Tok mais il
y a bien un moment il va falloir que
vous rendiez compte de vos agissements
de vos devant votre conseil et là vous
êtes vous allez être obligé de rompre si
le cas se présenter de te rompre
l'accord éventuel que vous auriez
accepté enfin c'est un peu ubuesque où
j'exagère dans ce que je vous exagérez
pas on a en réalité on n'a jamais été
confronté à ce type de demande avec
aucune plateforme c'est tout à fait
normal de signer un accord de
confidentialité sur le niveau des
négociations et nous informons
régulièrement notre conseil
d'administration de l'état des
négociations et c'est pour cette raison
que ça à cause de cette demande de
TikTok que nous avons toujours pas signé
d'accord de confidentialité que nous ne
sommes pas rentrés véritablement dans
des négociations et que pour le moment
pour contourner la difficulté on négocie
en présence d'avocat ce qui garantit
aussi la confidentialité des des
discussions mais c'est
honnêtement j'ai jamais rencontré des
gens pareils voilà c'est tout bon mais
je vous le dis j'ai jamais rencontré le
dirigeant du Parti communiste chinois de
ma vie non plus
en fait ce qui nous demandait
précisément c'est de on pouvait faire
état qu'il existait des discussions il
aurait pu exister des discussions entre
nous et Tik Tok mais il voulait qu'on
s'interdise contractuellement via cet
accord de confidentialité de dire quel
était l'objet de ces discussions or nous
le seul intérêt de même que sur mes
temps on a une discussion 18 mois et
pendant 18 mois on a dit aux auteurs les
discussions avancent on va aboutir et on
discute de votre rémunération et du
respect de votre droit moral sur les
plateformes de méta et donc on voulait
juste être en mesure de pouvoir dire
cette même phrase très générale et ça ça
posait un problème de principe à Tik Tok
qui a effectivement fait à choper
complètement les discussions sur
l'accord de confidentialité ça sachant
que pendant tout ce temps là et il y a
la différence des autres plateformes
digitales Tik Tok ne nous donne aucun
moyen
de savoir quels sont les œuvres qui de
qu'on représente qui sont présents sur
la plateforme donc on vous communiquera
le relevé de constatation qu'on a fait
faire à l'ALPA mais c'est c'est un
échantillon assez marginal de des
dizaines de milliers d'œuvres
représentées par la SACD qui sont sur
TikTok alors que par exemple YouTube
nous communique c'est des gros fichiers
extrêmement riches qu'on retraite
informatiquement et dans lequel on
identifie
l'intégralité des oeuvres qu'on
représente par des moyens informatiques
normaux et TikTok aujourd'hui nous dit
dites moi quels sont vos œuvres sur Tik
Tok et quand vous m'aurez dit ça on
pourra commencer à discuter ce qui est
intéressant c'est que vous verrez dans
le constat de la part c'est que
l'enquêteur a dû tout faire manuellement
parce qu'il explique lui-même qu'il n'y
a pas le moteur capable de faire
l'ensemble des repérages par rapport à
notre répertoire donc ce constat est
absolument accablant pour Tik Tok donc
si jamais les négociations n'aboutissent
pas je
devance votre question évidemment on ira
devant les tribunaux et on a signera Tik
Tok ça aucun doute j'ai jamais hésité à
signer
ceux qui ne payaient pas
merci beaucoup
quelques questions peut-être
pour commencer peut-être quelques
demandes de précision vous nous avez dit
Monsieur le Directeur Général que vous
n'avez
jamais
dans votre pratique jusqu'à lors était
l'objet de menaces de ce de cette nature
est-ce que vous pouvez nous préciser ce
que
vous entendez par menace dire le fait
qu'on vous dise c'est pas bien d'avoir
cité le président de la République
c'est pas c'est pas en soi une menace
d'ailleurs je vois pas de quoi on
pourrait vous menacer mais de quelle
menace à quelle menace faites-vous
allusion les menaces c'est d'aller
devant les tribunaux pour diffamation
c'est tout d'accord et alors c'est vrai
ça va être dur de vous étiez en
diffamation
je reconnais que de temps en temps il
suffit de suivre mon compte twitter je
suis assez agressif sur Tik Tok puisque
je ne fais que reprendre tous les
articles de journaux et ils sont
extrêmement
nombreux à la fois sur le non respect
des données personnelles sur les
problèmes qu'ils ont avec les
adolescents et les enfants ils ont eu
d'ailleurs une condamnation récemment en
Grande-Bretagne je ne parle même pas des
problèmes aux États-Unis parce que on
peut dire que dans les relations entre
Tik Tok et les Américains il y a aussi
des considérations politiques de
politiques intérieures américaines qui
sont un peu extérieures à notre sujet
mais ça s'arrête là donc la littérature
sur TikTok depuis quelques mois et
extrêmement
significative et elle est d'autres c'est
d'autant plus important que que Tik Tok
est quand même l'application qui a en
termes de vue auprès des plus jeunes le
plus progressé ces derniers mois c'est
pour ça que votre commission d'enquête
est extrêmement utile
merci beaucoup je voulais vous demander
une deuxième précision vous nous avez
dit tout à l'heure que
l'autre discussion aujourd'hui est
obligée de se mener par l'intermédiaire
d'avocat pour les raisons que vous
n'avez que vous nous avez expliqué ce
qui complique ce qui complexifie
beaucoup les discussions avez-vous dit
Monsieur Rodez plus loin en lui disant
des facto il y a aujourd'hui aucune
discussion avec TikTok alors est-ce que
vous pouvez nous préciser un peu est-ce
que c'est parce que ces discussions par
l'intérieur d'avocats portent sur le
préalable c'est-à-dire sur le vous
n'avez même pas réglé le problème de la
confidentialité et de l'accord de
confidentialité ou est-ce que il y a
tout de même
par l'intermédiaire d'avocat des
discussions sur le fond
non la présence des avocats permet de se
passer de l'accord de confidentialité
puisque la manière dont on organise les
discussions et si on était amenés à se
transmettre des informations de part et
d'autre du coup elle serait transmise
via avocat et sa préserverait la
confidentialité et par contre on a
effectivement pas eu d'échange sur le
fond de l'accord sur puisque la manière
dont on procède on a l'habitude on a des
accords avec tout le monde comme Pascal
regarde le disait c'est il faut qu'on
puisse évaluer le poids de notre
répertoire au sein de la plateforme et
TikTok qui à notre connaissance et pas
une entreprise dénuée de capacité en
termes d'Haïti d'intelligence
artificielle et normalement beaucoup
plus doté dans ces matières que la SACD
prétend ne pas être en mesure de nous
donner le moindre fichiers informatiques
pour nous permettre de reconnaître nos
œuvres donc on va à la pêche on a fait
via l'ALPA
des constats mais on sait pas ici on a
50000 œuvres ou 500 000 oeuvres sur TiK
ToK on sait pas si elle représente 5
milliards de vues ou 50 milliards de
vues et ça on ne pourra le savoir que
lorsqu'on aura pu rentrer dans des
discussions très concrètes avec Tik Tok
et ça fait deux ans qu'on attend pour
ouvrir ces discussions et c'est le poids
de notre répertoire sur la plateforme
qui après permettra d'avancer sur les
discussions du prix puisque si suivant
les plateformes on peut être avoir une
représentativité faible ou forte moyenne
ou forte et en fonction de ça les prix
va ce que je veux aussi expliquer c'est
que en gros Tik Tok et quand même
positionné comme concurrent YouTube et
avec Youtube nous avons des relations
tout à fait normal nous rémunirons les
ce qu'on appelle les youtubeurs et
autres et on ne peut pas se permettre
d'avoir à la au nombre de vues
équivalents des rémunérations
complètement différentes entre Tik Tok
et YouTube donc on doit faire attention
parce que comme une partie de cette
création peut migrer on doit faire
attention à être à respecter un principe
d'égalité entre les plateformes c'est
d'ailleurs une obligation de la
directive européenne nous devons
respecter une égalité de traitement
entre des diffuseurs comparables
une autre demande de précision vous nous
avez dit tout à l'heure avec les
sociétés américaines les discussions
sont compliquées mais possible
compliqué parce que ceux qui sont en
France doivent en référer à leur maison
mère
ce qui est bien entendu tout à fait
comprendre aussi et vous avez dit pour
TikTok c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
nous n'arrivons à rien et je n'ai disiez
vous il est vrai que je n'ai jusqu'à je
n'avais jusqu'à présent j'avais discuté
avec le Parti communiste chinois ce qui
infère que quelque part et d'une façon
ou d'une autre c'est ce que nous sommes
d'ailleurs en train d'essayer de de
mettre à jour
Tik Tok dépend d'une entreprise chinoise
ou dépendrait d'une entreprise chinoise
ma demande de précision est la suivante
donc quand vous discutez avec Tik Tok en
dehors des avocats avec qui vous ausité
tout un monsieur gérandeau je ne sais
pas si c'est avec lui que vous discutez
avec qui monsieur guerrando pardon avec
qui vous discutez et est-ce que vous
savez à qui il aurait fait si Tik Tok
est une société française capable de
prendre des décisions autonomes par
rapport à la SACD ou si elle doit en
référer à un bord européen
un référent européen ou un référent
chinois
alors comme je disais Pascal tout à
l'heure eric Garandeau et uniquement
dans des fonctions telles qu'on les
perçoit de stratégie d'influence et
distribution
de subsides à des acteurs de la culture
française donc ils ont rencontré
initialement parce qu'on le connaissait
au titre de ces anciennes fonctions mais
il est absolument dans aucune des
discussions et c'est pas très simple de
répondre à votre question parce que
depuis le début des discussions avec eux
j'ai dû voir 7 ou 8 personnes en visio
en présentiel basé à Londres à Paris et
nous on a l'habitude de discuter soit
avec des représentants à Paris soit
parfois les sièges européens sont à
Londres ou en Irlande et on peut mener
les discussions à Paris ou à l'étranger
en français ou en anglais c'est pas pour
nous un problème après il sait pas
illégitime qu'une société en réfère à sa
gouvernance on connaît pas en détail la
gouvernance de Tik Tok de même qu'on
connaît pas en détail la gouvernance des
processus de prise de décision chez meta
ou chez YouTube mais ça ça n'a jamais
été un obstacle à la finalisation
des accords et ce que je voulais dire
sur le fait que c'est effectivement plus
long souvent de négocier avec les
plateformes américaines mais par contre
ce qu'on a pu constater c'est qu'elles
sont une fois qu'on a un accord signé un
contrat
sont c'est extrêmement simple dans
l'exécution d'un contrat il s'est même
souvent beaucoup plus simple qu'à vers
certains acteurs français ou à peine un
contrat signé qui est toujours des
petites discussions complémentaires pour
sur l'exécution du contrat donc la
difficulté enfin la stratégie les
modalités de et les pratiques
contractuelles ces grands compats
américains ils cherchent à résoudre les
problèmes susceptibles de se poser avant
le contrat d'où la longueur des
discussions et par contre une fois le
contrat signé
il s'exécute aussi bien avec toutes les
plateformes que c'était Pascal tout à
l'heure YouTube et meta mais aussi les
plateformes
comme Netflix Amazon et Disney de
manière extrêmement fluide je voudrais
juste dire que
ça dépend de chaque plateforme on est
des discussions très faciles avec
Netflix on a d'ailleurs fait la
connaissance du grand patron redastine
du secrétaire général
juridique qui suit l'ensemble de ces
questions je sais pas si vous le savez
mais le patron actuel de TF1 Ronald
belle-mère a été au conseil
d'administration de Netflix donc ça
facilité des relations et c'est c'est
pas les oppositions même
franco-américaines c'est pas pareil de
négocier avec Disney avec Netflix et
c'est pas du tout pareil avec Amazon qui
a aussi d'autres métiers et nous avons
rencontré d'énormes difficultés j'ai
d'ailleurs été sur la place publique
avec Canal+ qui a même cessé brutalement
d'exécuter un contrat de nous payer pour
faire baisser les rémunérations de
droits d'auteur de 30% et qu'on a été
obligé d'assigner bon mais une semaine
avant de l'assignation mystérieusement
les choses se sont réglées bon enfin
avant qu'on aille au tribunal en référé
bon mais donc chaque mais là on est dans
un devant un mur d'opacité
honnêtement que je n'ai jamais rencontré
depuis que je suis à la SACD donc ça
fait 20 ans
vous nous indiquez qu'il y a différentes
personnes avec qui vous discutez tantôt
français tantôt d'un board en
Grande-Bretagne
est-ce que vous pouvez nous communiquer
la liste de ces personnes avec leur
fonction ou est-ce que les accords de
confidentialité vous empêchent de
publier cette de nous communiquer leur
nom
je ne voulais donc pas dans la
confidentialité donc voilà on peut on
pourra vous communiquer les noms des
personnes et pour certaines d'entre
elles on connaît leur fonction et pour
d'autres moins
merci beaucoup
vous dites qu'il est extrêmement
difficile de chiffrer les pertes de
recettes par rapport bien entendu aux
auteurs puisqu'en ne vous communique pas
les fichiers informatiques et je
comprends à quel point et quand on voit
la rue vitesse à laquelle déroule les
vidéos et les programmes c'est un petit
peu particulier
donc j'imagine que vous ne pouvez pas
arriver à une précision
complète mais d'après ce que
[Musique]
vous avez recueilli vous-même à la main
comme vous dites est-ce que vous pouvez
nous donner une fourchette de la perte
de recettes associée à la diffusion sur
Tik Tok des oeuvres des auteurs membres
de la SACD
non là enfin toute transparence à ce
stade des discussions on n'a pas la
moindre idée de ce qu'on va demander sur
le plan financier
à TiK ToK on a des ordres de grandeur
puisqu'on a des accords avec méta avec
Youtube et
le cadre général de nos accords c'est
qu'on demande un certain pourcentage du
chiffre d'affaires en France et en
Belgique de ces plateformes et donc on a
des ordres de grandeur en tête qui
correspondent
à ce qu'on peut avoir sur meta ou sur
Youtube mais mais encore faut-il qu'il
rentre en détail sur le notre
représentativité précise sur la
plateforme donc c'est un dialogue
légitime un débat légitime qu'on doit
avoir avec Tik Tok qu'on a eu avec les
autres plateformes et qui n'a pas du
tout commencé
mais par rapport à YouTube par exemple
quand on n'est pas dans dans
je pense
que c'est au moins au niveau de ça doit
être au moins au niveau de YouTube voilà
parce que avec YouTube
a été au moment de la directive aura
d'auteur
ces critiqué d'ailleurs j'ai trouvé ça
plutôt injuste parce que nous avons
passé bien avant la directive droit
d'auteur des accords avec eux je me
souviens de la première discussion
c'était amusante parce que on avait vu
un représentant de YouTube qui est et on
l'avait dit que on voulait dans la
rémunération proportionnelle recettes
d'exploitation et nous avait dit non non
je veux bien vous donner un forfait tout
aussi important que le pourcentage mais
je ne céderai pas sur le sur le principe
de la rémunération conventionnelle je
lui ai dit moi non plus puisque nous
avons la rémunération proportionnelle
depuis 1791
bon et il est revenu 6 mois après et on
a finalement passé un accord sur la base
de ce principe du droit d'auteur à la
française qui est maintenant le grâce au
vote du Parlement européen et aussi à
l'engagement du gouvernement français
qui est maintenant la règle en Europe
donc moi j'estime une née que pour le
moment compte tenu parce qu'en plus la
progression de Tik Tok est très rapide
sur ces il y a deux trois ans on en
parlait quasiment pas je pense qu'ils
sont au moins au niveau de YouTube
et on ne parle à date au monde cette
audition on n'a pas la moindre idée du
chiffre d'affaires de Tik Tok enfin
ninozoeuvre ni le chiffre d'affaires de
Tik Tok en France donc c'est c'est
merci bien
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de
piraterie audiovisuelle
et vous nous avez dit que vous êtes en
contact avec l'association de lutte
contre la piraterie audiovisuelle à ce
sujet est-ce que cette association a le
même diagnostic que vous est-ce qu'il
s'agit pour vous et comme pour elle de
piraterie audiovisuelle et en gros
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
peu plus de vos relations avec l'ALPA
sur le sujet Tik Tok et la position de
l'ALPA par rapport à ce sujet on a de
très bonnes relations avec l'ALPA parce
qu'on est membre de l'alpart donc on
finance l'alpha au côté de nombreuses
organisations professionnelles
françaises aux côtés de l'ANPE
l'association la société des des
producteurs américains et j'ai
personnellement des très bonnes
relations avec son président
Nicolas sedoux donc j'ai alerté Nicolas
Seydoux sur le sujet
nous avons discuté avec Frédéric
Delacroix que leur délégué général et
c'est comme ça que l'ALPA a pu faire le
constat que je vous fournirai à la suite
de l'audition et vous verrez en lisant
le constat que ce qu'on vous a raconté
c'est la vérité il y a parce que c'est
un agent assermenté qui a constaté
en passant une journée à la main
naturellement devant son ordinateur qui
avait énormément d'oeuvres du répertoire
de la SACD qui était diffusée alors dans
ses œuvres je suppose qu'il y en a
certaines qui ont peut-être été
autorisés par leurs producteurs parce
que l'autorisation de la SACD sur une
œuvre de visuelle ne suffit pas et
d'autres qui sont des œuvres qui sont
piratées mais on n'a pas connaissance
non plus de ce que fait Tik Tok à la
différence par exemple de YouTube pour
protéger contre la piraterie vous savez
sur Youtube vous avez un système qui
s'appelle Quentin taidi ou vous pouvez
vous pouvez marquer votre œuvre et le
principe c'est qu'une fois que l'oeuvre
est marquée elle ne rentre pas dans le
système YouTube c'est-à-dire si un
particulier veut poster un bout de film
un extrait de film pour le faire
diffuser sur Youtube ça ne passe pas
parce que c'est c'est bloqué par le par
le système de protection et c'est
d'ailleurs la meilleure manière de se
protéger c'est c'est d'empêcher que que
sa fille sur l'Internet donc la
protection contre la piraterie sur les
plateformes dès lors que la plateforme à
la volonté de faire cette protection et
que les ayants droits
font attention à se protéger et donc
font les marquages nécessaires elle est
finalement
assez simple mais d'ailleurs la
piraterie audiovisuelle a quand même un
peu baissé ces derniers temps du fait de
l'augmentation de la diffusion par les
plateformes et de la facilité que le
public a maintenant à se procurer aussi
bien les œuvres musicales que les œuvres
audiovisuelles et cinématographiques par
des par des plateformes payantes qui se
font une concurrence d'ailleurs assez
effrénée en ce moment
a mis en place des mécanismes
opérationnels avec les plateformes il y
a un accord qui fonctionne sur le plan
technique entre YouTube et l'ALPA et qui
permet en fait d'accélérer encore les
processus de retrait des œuvres qui
auraient été piratées ce que je voulais
juste ajouter c'est que nous la SACD
notre but c'est que c'est pas
d'interdire la diffusion des œuvres des
auteurs qu'on représente c'est c'est au
contraire de l'autoriser
dans le double respect du droit moral et
du droit à rémunération proportionnelle
et le seul message à peu près
compréhensible que nous donne Tik Tok
c'est dites moi quelles œuvres je dois
retirer
vous nous avez parlé tout à l'heure
d'un épisode du festival du
court-métrage où le président s'est
retiré puis est revenu
est-ce que
en raison de pression sur les sur les
lauréats du festival est-ce que cet
épisode a donné lieu à des analyses à
des reportages des articles et ce que
vous pourriez nous
après cette audition nous nous les
communiquait il y a des articles vous
faites rétypan c'est sur le moteur de
recherche bien connu vous faites ritipan
Tik Tok et vous aurez toute une liste
d'articles il y a même une vidéo je
crois que sur Youtube où il explique
qu'il s'est retiré avec deux autres
membres de son jury parce qu'ils ont Tik
Tok voulait lui faire subir des
pressions et je suppose que c'était
dépression sur le choix des lauréats
qu'il a eu une discussion avec Tik Tok
que Tik Tok a cédé lui a assuré de de
son indépendance de sa liberté et donc
il explique qu'il est revenu parce qu'il
était important pour lui
de donner des prix à des jeunes qui
faisaient de la création mais c'est
quand même assez scandaleux qu'en plein
milieu du Festival de Cannes vous ayez
une opération de promotion d'une
entreprise pirate voilà c'est tout
je voulais vous poser une dernière
question avant de laisser mes collègues
le faire de leur côté
est-ce que le règlement le DJ tôle
service actes européen
vous
paraît susceptible
d'entraîner une véritable
responsabilisation des plateformes et
notamment quelles sont ses conséquences
et il y en a t-il sur la protection des
œuvres audiovisuelles
respecter le droit à l'auteur mais si on
fait respecter le droit d'auteur et que
c'est au détriment des règles
européennes sur les données personnelles
par exemple
ça n'est pas non plus satisfaisant pour
nous moi je ne veux pas apparaître comme
quelqu'un qui servirait les intérêts de
TikTok alors que cette entreprise
contournerait une législation européenne
que nous souhaitons voire respecter et
qui est très positive pour sur la
protection des données personnelles
merci beaucoup j'en ai fini pour le
moment avec mes questions
[Musique]
souhaitent intervenir alors Monsieur
gatelin oui merci monsieur le Président
merci de vous entendre parce que quand
on discute avec certains interlocuteurs
y compris des soi-disant ce mités du
numérique en France qui ont eu de
lourdes responsabilités on nous dit Tik
Tok font comme les américains il y a pas
de différence entre les plateformes ce
qui est quand même assez surréal et là
vous l'avez très très bien démontré je
suis arrivé avec quelques minutes de
retard mais
j'ai oui dire que un certain nombre de
taxes notamment sur les recettes
publicitaires ou sur les services vidéo
n'était pas à qui était par Tik Tok donc
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez confirmer
cette chose là parce que il y a cette
contribution j'en profite j'ai deux
trois petites questions mais je pense
que c'est ce qu'on nous a dit mais vous
pouvez vérifier ça très rapidement
intéressant un coup de fil à Dominique
Boutonnat Olivier Henrard les dirigeants
du Centre national du cinéma puisque moi
je pense qu'ils doivent la taxe comme
les autres opérateurs qui diffusent des
œuvres
d'accord par ailleurs vous l'avez
souligné il y a une absence incroyable
de transparence sur les chiffres vous
disiez que vous ne connaissiez pas le
chiffre d'affaires de Tik Tok en France
mais on le connaît pas tellement plus au
niveau international ce qui est assez
étonnant j'essaye déjà depuis plusieurs
semaines à partir de données très épars
de
d'évaluer l'entreprise strict Tik Tok
alors rien n'est clair avec sa filiale
by dance on sait pas non plus parfois
s'il s'agit de tiktor Tik Tok pur sucre
ou on inclut yudine donc la fille des
chinoise qui a un modèle financier très
particulier parce que pour le coup c'est
une plateforme aussi de vente en ligne
ce n'est pas Tik Tok et on arrive à des
conclusions quand je regarde les
évolutions des recettes publicitaires
parce que là c'est à peu près bien fait
au niveau international on sait à peu
près ce qu'on gagne ça représenterait
moins de la moitié du chiffre d'affaires
alors c'est quoi l'autre chiffre
d'affaires surtout quand Tik Tok prétend
rémunérer les créateurs de contenu les
influenceurs par le même de leur donner
un intéressement je ne comprends pas
personnellement le modèle économique
parce que la publicité est pas très
aisée à mettre sur des programmes
extrêmement courts il semblerait que
certaines tentatives fait partie de
l'intensification de la publicité et
provoquer une fuite de certains
auditeurs donc je n'arrive pas à
comprendre et est-ce qu'une entreprise
qui diffuse dans un pays officiellement
comme la France n'a pas obligation à
fournir des comptes enfin il y a très
peu quand même d'entreprises dans ce
pays qui ne sont pas
sujettes à déclaration auprès des
services fiscaux avec aussi
l'établissement contrôle des contrôleurs
aux comptes comment peut-on avoir ces
données de vos points de vue de votre
point de vue
je pense que vous devriez auditionner le
directeur général des finances publiques
qui vous dirait s'il arrive à avoir des
renseignements sur eux le gros problème
de Tik Tok c'est l'absence de complète
de transparence de la gouvernance quand
vous avez affaire à une entreprise
américaine vous avez en général des
entreprises côté embauche qui doivent
rendre des comptes à leurs sectionnaires
et le moindre flottement sur les abonnés
de Netflix ou sur les recettes de
Netflix c'est connu dans le monde entier
le lendemain vous avez des articles qui
se porte moins bien ou il se porte mieux
donc je pense que
franchement il y a un lot d'opacité
je peux pas rien dire d'autre autour de
cette entreprise qui justement justifie
absolument cette cette commission
enquête et je crois que si nous-même
nous nous retons assez difficultés c'est
parce que ils n'ont pas une
compréhension très grande mais qu'ils
aient ce spécialiste Garandeau à côté
d'eux mais il a pas l'air de passer du
côté du respect du droit d'auteur
ils n'ont en fait ils sont dans un autre
univers j'ai l'impression ils sont pas
dans notre univers classique et je le
redis les entreprises américaines les
discussions dans certains cas et pas
toujours peuvent être longues mais une
fois que la discussion
aboutit ils sont parfaitement
respectueux des contrats qu'ils ont
passé je n'ai jamais eu de difficultés
là avec Amazon on a d'ailleurs des
partenariats avec eux j'en ai pas avec
Netflix et j'en ai pas avec Disney donc
j'en aurais peut-être dans le futur mais
ce sont des entreprises sérieuses et en
plus ces entreprises sont aussi
des producteurs donc ils ont conscience
de la valeur de de la propriété
intellectuelle et de la nécessité de le
respecter mais je trouve que ce que
j'espère c'est que votre commission
d'enquête arrivera à lever le voile sur
Tik Tok et à comprendre ce qui se passe
là il paraît qu'il y a eu des mouvements
il y avait un article là dessus sur
l'actionnariat de Tik Tok des mouvements
assez curieux
voilà
juste compléter vous avez dit
qu'effectivement on voyait nous à la
SACD une différence entre les
plateformes américaines et la plateforme
TikTok qui est chinoise il y a pas que
la SACD de l'arcom dans le cadre des
nouvelles missions que lui a confié le
Parlement à mener une enquête
approfondie sur les pratiques à élaborer
un questionnaire
c'est à eux de vous en parler plus en
détail mais la seule plateforme qui n'a
pas contribué à ce travail et qui a fait
des réponses lacunaires c'est Tik Tok
[Musique]
y a-t-il d'autres questions j'en ai une
sinon mais oui merci et Monsieur ensuite
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Laporte mes chers collègues je voudrais
comprendre quelque chose
ça m'échappe je comprends l'intérêt que
Tik Tok peut avoir avec des partenariats
tels que le Festival de Cannes vous nous
avez expliqué les musées nationaux le
Salon du livre mais qu'elle est l'enjeu
et l'intérêt pour le Salon du livre La
Réunion des musées etc à avoir un
partenariat entre guillemets avec TikTok
est-ce que c'est un intérêt financier
est-ce que c'est pour se justifier de
quelque chose
est-ce que vous pouvez éclairer ma
lanterne à ce sujet ma deuxième remarque
c'est l'arcome alors vous parlez du mur
d'opacité c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui me parle
l'arcome probablement grâce à vous et
effectivement réussi à enlever des
plateformes le contenu du du candidat à
la présence de la République ça a été
enlevé en trois jours en France il y a
une loi qui a été votée le 30 juillet
2020 pour que les enfants ne puissent
pas être exposés à des contenus
pornographiques sur les sites gratuits
l'art comme a mis en justice plusieurs
sites un nombre x sans vouloir faire de
l'humour
n'arrive à rien
n'arrive à rien du tout donc le mur de
l'opacité j'ai l'impression qu'il
s'édifie
dans tout un tas de sujets il n'arrive à
rien puisque même le tribunal judiciaire
de Paris a nommé un médiateur comme quoi
il n'était pas capable de juger cette
médiation l'art comme l'a quitté en
disant qu'elle était juste absolument
inutile et stupide on attend le délibéré
pour le mois de juillet pour une autre
plateforme qui n'est toujours pas
conformité avec la loi donc j'aimerais
sur ces deux points que vous m'apportiez
votre éclaircissement
sur le salon du livre c'est classique on
vous fait un chèque vous êtes content
voilà simplement
on a reçu il y a à peu près il y a un
mois elle est satiété tous les grands
éditeurs français et je leur ai expliqué
les problèmes qu'on avait avec Tik Tok
et ils sont concernés puisqu'en été ils
sont aussi au droit des auteurs dont les
œuvres sont adaptées pour faire des
séries ou des films de cinéma et
certains ont été horrifiés par ce
partenariat parce qu'ils étaient pas au
courant alité des problèmes que que
posait Tik Tok au niveau du du respect
du droit d'auteur donc ils sont
peut-être plus
vigilants la prochaine fois mais quand
vous avez quelqu'un qui arrive et qui
vous propose des sommes d'argent le
Festival de Cannes la seule réponse et
on a besoin de l'argent bon bah d'accord
on peut aussi pactiser avec le diable si
on a une longue mais quand même donc
après pour votre
deuxième alors ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre cette stratégie d'influence
c'est qu'elle est complètement orientée
vers des institutions culturelles donc
c'est un choix qui est fait bon et donc
sur le choix doit remonter plus haut je
vois pas toutes les
intentions d'infiltration qu'il y a
derrière tout ça mais pour la question
des oeuvres pornographiques ça je suis
pas bien au courant du sujet et je ne
peux pas vous répondre je sais
simplement que c'est extrêmement
compliqué pour les autorités de
régulation de bloquer l'accès parce que
ça demande la fourniture de documents
d'identité enfin de certification qui
sont
qui sont considérés par d'autres comme
portant atteinte aux libertés publiques
voilà c'est mais c'est vrai que il y a
une sorte de diffusion de la
pornographie par certaines plateformes
mais là je cite pas du tout TikTok qui
est extrêmement importante et que c'est
aussi aux parents parce que il y a
maintenant des sur les ordinateurs vous
avez des outils qui normalement doivent
vous permettre d'essayer de contrôler
même si c'est au fur et à mesure que
l'enfant grandit c'est une tâche
quasiment impossible
c'est pas aux parents de de faire en
sorte que l'enfant ne voit pas au milieu
de la rue le type qui se balade à poil
c'est le type qui ne doit pas porter
atteinte à la pudeur donc oui
merci Monsieur le merci monsieur le
Président merci pour la qualité la
précision de votre propos juste une
petite remarque par rapport à ce qui
vient d'être dit j'espère monsieur le
monsieur le Président de la Commission
que nous pourrons avoir des informations
précises sur les montants touchés par
des organismes publics ce que cela au
moins je crois qu'ils peuvent pas être
cachés à la représentation nationale
j'aimerais bien comprendre qu'elle
pourrait être la mécanique juridique que
vous pourriez mettre en oeuvre pour
obliger Tik Tok à respecter le droit
d'auteur comment ça s'articule à la fois
par rapport à la législation française
la législation européenne et ce qui
pourrait être engagé du côté irlandais
et oui parce qu'il y a les il y a cette
interaction qui est pas facile à
comprendre et qu'est-ce que vous
pourriez en tirer et en quoi elle
pourrait obliger inhiner TikTok a changé
complètement son système entre de façon
très très simple est-ce que finalement
ils ne sont pas prêts à payer une amende
même même très lourdes et à continuer
des pratiques qui leur apportent sans
doute beaucoup plus
long parce que si
je voulais dire on privilégie toujours
la discussion la négociation parce qu'il
y a un moment donné il vaut mieux avoir
des rapports de confiance avec ces
entreprises qui diffusent les œuvres de
notre répertoire ne serait-ce que pour
avoir l'ensemble des données qui nous
permettent de rémunérer les auteurs mais
c'est très simple si nous n'arrivons pas
dans un délai raisonnable un accord nous
allons les assigner en France vu qu'on
peut des tribunaux sont compétents pour
contrefaçon et
en France le droit d'auteur est
extrêmement bien défendu par les juges
on en a eu la preuve au moment de cette
élection présidentielle voilà où c'était
pas si simple que ça d'ailleurs
donc
j'ai toute confiance parce que on a une
directive européenne sur le droit
d'auteur qui était compliqué à faire
adopter je rappelle qu'il y a eu des
campagnes contre la directive
extrêmement importante de la part des
grandes entreprises de l'Internet et que
le premier vote au Parlement européen la
directive a été refusée elle n'a pas été
adoptée on a dû aller ensuite à nouveau
en discussion et là je remercie vraiment
le gouvernement français du soutien qui
nous a apporté et qu'il a porté à toute
la Création européenne pour défendre
cette directive ensuite une
transposition par ordonnance parce qu'on
était en pleine période covid très
ambitieuse réalisée par le premier
ministre Jean Castex et donc on a tous
les outils pour faire respecter le droit
d'auteur en France aussi bien le droit
patrimonial c'est à dire la rémunération
que le droit moral et puis à un moment
donné après je sais pas comment on
attrape les dirigeants mais le
non-respect du droit d'auteur c'est
aussi du pénal bon donc on a priori on
va jamais au pénal parce que ce qui nous
compte pour nous c'est de nous faire
rémunérer c'est pas de faire condamner
ceux qui ne respectent pas les règles
mais les dispositions en France sur le
respect du droit d'auteur et maintenant
même en Europe mais en tout cas en
France sont extrêmement puissantes et je
n'ai aucun doute qu'à la fin Tik Tok
sera condamné et si il est condamné en
France qui est quand même un pays
symbolique pour le respect du droit
d'auteur compte tenu des ennuis qu'il a
aussi aux États-Unis il y a actuellement
des menaces d'interdiction de la
plateforme extrêmement sérieuse et dans
d'autres pays je pense que ça va aller
faire réfléchir donc le
problème droit d'auteur en réalité c'est
encore une pièce qui
s'ajoute à des tas de problèmes qu'il
pose
de non-respect et de non compréhension
des règles de droit en Europe et dans
notre pays
[Musique]
une autre question qui a appelé une
réponse peut-être un peu subjective donc
vous y répondrez ou pas mais
à quoi est-ce que vous attribuez le fait
qu'à la différence des autres
négociations que vous avez pu mener par
le passé
vous ne semblez pas toujours avoir
affaire aux mêmes personnes en tout cas
vous n'êtes pas à faire à des
négociateurs aussi bien identifiés on va
dire pour être prudent
quel est l'intérêt de la plateforme de
ne pas chercher à régler le problème
pour qu'il soit derrière tout le monde
et de pouvoir avancer quel est leur
intérêt de faire de la piraterie c'est
votre terme plutôt qu'autre chose donc
en clair ma question est à quoi est-ce
que vous attribuez
cette absence de volonté manifeste de
régler la discussion est-ce que c'est
est-ce que c'est culturel ce que c'est
une approche de la question du droit
d'auteur qui est différente et qu'est-ce
qui ferait pour compléter ma question
que les représentants français ou ceux
qui travaillent dans l'intérêt de
l'entreprise et c'est pas interdit ne
soit pas en mesure de leur expliquer la
vision
française et pas seulement française des
choses s'agissant du droit d'auteur
qu'est-ce qui justifie tout ça qu'est-ce
qui justifie ce bras de fer moi je pense
que cette entreprise est une énigme et
que pour le moment personne n'a la
réponse personne ne sait vraiment qui
contrôle cette entreprise
est-ce que c'est le patron du Parti
communiste chinois qui est la contrôle
ce que ce sont des actionnaires français
pas français chinois ou américain on ne
sait pas
donc
c'est vraiment un univers très spécial
et d'ailleurs vous avez une idée de
faire une commission d'enquête vous
n'avez pas eu l'idée de faire une
commission d'enquête sur Netflix Amazon
ou Disney qui sont des entreprises
connues reconnues côté en bourse et dont
le fonctionnement est normal par rapport
à la vie des affaires là on a affaire à
un autre monde on sait absolument pas si
cette entreprise en réalité là pour
récolter des données personnelles faire
autre chose avoir des activités
parallèles faire de l'espionnage je peux
pas vous répondre et ça mériterait
j'ai écouté d'ailleurs un intervenant
devant la commission qui était un
spécialiste reste de l'influence de la
Chine et il n'avait enfin lui il
répondait que c'était un outil de
l'influence de la Chine Tic-Toc mais il
n'était pas non plus capable de donner
des explications
précises sur le fonctionnement de cette
entreprise on a aucune transparence non
plus sur la hiérarchie je vous dis vous
avez une personne qui pour le monde
culturel incarne l'entreprise parce
qu'il a son carré de chèques et Eric
Garandeau l'inspecteur des finances
d'ailleurs je sais pas pourquoi il est
toujours inspection des finances non ça
je vous pose la question
non mais c'est quand même assez
hallucinant alors que j'ai loupé votre
remarque je vous ai dit on ne sait pas
je ne sais pas pourquoi il est encore à
l'Inspection des finances je pourrais
poser la question d'enquête en soi je
pourrais poser la question à Bruno Le
Maire voilà je sais pas bon
c'est parce que chez non je suis
extrêmement choqué par le fait qu'une
entreprise
installez sur le territoire français
absolument non respectueuse des droits
d'auteur et qui se moque de nous depuis
plus d'un an et à côté quelqu'un qui
incarné le chèque et qui signe des
partenariats avec les grandes
institutions culturelles françaises
c'est extrêmement choquant et j'ai écrit
au mois de décembre dernier au Festival
de Cannes pour dire que j'appréciais pas
du tout le partenariat qui savait et la
seule réponse que j'ai eue on a besoin
d'argent je suis choqué voilà
une autre question il semble que la
SACEM est une un peu plus de chance que
vous puisque apparemment elle aurait
signé un contrat avec Tik Tok est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire quelque chose
et est-ce que vous envisagez de vous
inspirer de ce de ce type de contrat
dans votre négociation avec Tik Tok
alors la SACEM c'est un peu différent de
nous parce qu'elle a un pouvoir de
négociation au départ qui est supérieur
parce que la SACEM c'est pas seulement
une société de l'auteur c'est une
société de droit d'auteur elle regroupe
aussi des éditeurs donc les producteurs
de musique et toutes les grandes
sociétés mondiales et comme il y a on
peut pas dire qu'il y a pas de musique
sur Tik Tok contester le répertoire
musical c'est extrêmement complexe par
contre alors je n'ai pas d'informations
parce que je savais que vous me poseriez
la question sur le contrat que la Sacem
a passé et la SACEM ne peut pas me
donner les informations parce que le
contrat lui-même est couvert par des
par la confidentialité alors cette
confidentialité c'est pas les garde tous
parce que la Loi sur le droit d'auteur
enfin c'est la transposition de la
directive européenne prévoit que les
auteurs membres d'un organisme de
gestion collective peuvent dans les deux
mois qui précèdent l'assemblée générale
de chaque organisme obtenir la
communication des contrats allez les
consulter sur place sous réserve du
droit des affaires s'il y a certaines
clauses qui peuvent ne pas être
communiqués donc les auteurs peuvent
avoir communication du contrat pendant
ces deux mois et d'ailleurs certains des
auteurs de la SACD je crois que c'est
l'année dernière sont venus parce que ça
leur paraissait très mystérieux
consulter le contrat Netflix je sais pas
pourquoi c'était Netflix il sortit ils
avaient lu le contrat en anglais ils
étaient contents
juste pour dire la vérification toutes
les sociétés musicales dans le monde
parce qu'elles représentent les éditeurs
et les auteurs ont des contrats avec
toutes les plateformes donc aussi avec
Tik Tok nous on a l'habitude à la SACD
d'être
pionnier parce que il y a peu de pays
qui protègent aussi bien les auteurs
audiovisuels et du spectacle vivant et
de l'humour et donc pour le contrat avec
que Pascal a négocié avec Youtube il y a
un peu plus de 10 ans c'était le premier
contrat signé par Youtube avec une
société d'auteur audiovisuel avec meta à
ma connaissance on est aussi le premier
voir le seul contrat alors que dans le
monde des sociétés d'auteurs musicales à
cause de cette complémentarité auteur
éditeur c'est systématiquement que les
plateformes signent des contraintes mais
pour autant du coup on passe plus de
temps à devoir expliquer le modèle
français
ou européen mais mais on y arrive quand
même j'ajoute beaucoup de choses c'est
que le droit à rémunération
proportionnelle des auteurs en Europe
n'a été reconnu que par la directive
européenne la dernière directive avant
dans les pays après ça va dépendre des
transpositions mais il y a des pays
comme l'Allemagne ou ce droit
rémunération proportionnelle n'était pas
reconnue alors qu'il est reconnu en
Espagne et qu'il est reconnu en Italie
donc la situation en Europe n'était pas
la même et donc les interlocuteurs ont
l'habitude de négocier avec les sociétés
musicales non pas pour des raisons de
droit mais parce que les sociétés
musicales représentent l'intégralité de
la musique mondiale parce qu'elles ont
en fait des accords de réciprocité entre
elles et donc elles sont totalement
incontournables et ils n'ont pas
forcément l'habitude de négocier avec
les sociétés qui représentent
l'audiovisuel ou le spectacle vivant
comme nous les captations parce que ce
droit a rémunération proportionnelle
était reconnue dans certains pays en
Europe mais pas dans tous les pays et
c'est une conquête à laquelle nous avons
aux côtés du gouvernement français
contribué que ce droit soit reconnu sur
l'ensemble de l'Europe c'est-à-dire beau
marché maintenant et sur l'ensemble de
l'Europe mais avant c'était limité à
quelques pays
s'il n'y a pas d'autres questions oui si
Monsieur Julias
juste un tout petit point d'histoire sur
l'intérêt de du Sénat pour pour tous ces
problèmes
le sénateur Gérard Longuet avait été
rapporteur d'une commission d'enquête
sur le devoir de souveraineté numérique
c'était en 2019 1er octobre 2019 il y
avait tout un chapitre consacré à ce que
tu es en train de mettre en place la
Chine je viens de vérifier le mot Tik
Tok n'est pas cité une seule fois donc
non pas que nous ayons pas vu le
problème à cette époque là c'est que en
4 ans il y a eu une modification
radicale et totale de tout cet
environnement numérique ce qui montre
qu'on est vraiment sur une une matière
qui est en évolution permanente et que
notre travail est d'essayer de courir
après toute cette évolution numérique
merci monsieur le Président j'aurai une
dernière petite question ça nous a été
suggéré par un des des universitaires
que nous avons auditionnées et puis à
l'occasion de rencontres diverses et
variantes on s'est posé la question
aussi est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
pour avoir commencé à échanger avec eux
depuis quelques mois et quand vous avez
vu exploser le nombre d'abonnés ce que
vous correz le sentiment de certains
selon lequel il serait je me fais un peu
l'avocat du diable tout simplement
déborder par leur croissance et qui ne
peuvent pas régler tous les problèmes en
même temps
ça je sais pas je sais pas quels sont
les moyens que le actionnaires donne à
l'entreprise mais non
ils sont vraiment spéciaux surtout je je
veux pas vous faire d'autres réponses je
n'ai jamais connu ça voilà j'ai connu
des difficultés avec des grandes
entreprises plutôt française d'ailleurs
qui étrangère
bon mais là c'est tout à fait spécial
c'est ces changements dans le management
cette sorte de dichotomie entre la
volonté d'investir la culture avec ses
partenariats et le carnet de chèques
l'autre côté le refus de reconnaître un
principe droit d'auteur
c'est il parait leur droit d'auteur mais
franchement ils vont pas en mourir donc
ça
n'exagère pas
je ne sais pas peut-être que
l'entreprise vous avez raison commence à
dysfonctionner parce qu'elle s'est
développée trop trop finalement et qui
n'ont pas forcément tous les moyens
humains mais ils ont quand même des
interlocuteurs on vous donnera les noms
à la sortie ça change beaucoup alors
c'est peut-être aussi pour ça qu'ils
sont un peu désorganisés mais enfin
engagé une négociation sérieuse avec
nous sur le respect du droit d'auteur on
fera nous c'est un classique il y a des
tas de gens qui savent le faire c'est
pas trop compliqué et à la fin ils
auraient au moins réglé un problème il
règlerait peut-être pas leurs problèmes
de données personnelles et tout mais là
on a l'impression qu'il les accumule ils
font l'objet de d'attaque dont certaines
sont politiques clairement côté
américain et je ne comprends pas
pourquoi sur cet aspect du droit
d'auteur
il se mettent pas aux normes comme tout
le monde quoi c'est tout toutes les
plateformes sont aux normes pourquoi
contribue pas
au fonctionnement du Centre national du
cinéma
comme la législation française le
prévoir enfin voilà c'est assez et
YouTube le fait par exemple YouTube
contribue et d'ailleurs le CNC par
ailleurs encaisse de l'argent mais il a
aussi créé un fond pour aider les
youtubeurs à créer des oeuvres ce qui
est intéressant pour des jeunes parce
que ils peuvent directement créer aller
en diffusion sans passer par des
commissions par des intermédiaires
sans sans complications excessive donc
je comprends pas
peut-être qu'il leur manque un grand
dirigeant un stratège en Europe enfin je
sais pas
pour moi c'est un choix stratégique de
l'entreprise qui privilégie la
croissance à tout prix et mobilise
toutes les ressources en interne pour
croître soit des fins
développement commercial normal d'une
entreprise soit à d'autres fins
sur lequel nous on n'a pas
d'informations mais tout le monde
s'interroge mais ce qui est clair c'est
que quand ils mobilise plus de moyens en
France sur les affaires publiques que
sur le rgpd ou sur le droit d'auteur
nous je sais pas combien vous avez
identifié d'interlocuteurs à faire
public chez TikTok en France mais nous
on a identifié au moins trois ou quatre
toutes les l'accompagnement et le
subventionnnement des différentes
institutions culturelles ça mobilisent
beaucoup d'énergie chez TikTok et c'est
un choix de là il y a beaucoup de
salariés qui sont recrutés affectés et
dotés de moyens pour mener ces
politiques lâcher Tik Tok alors que sur
le respect de la protection des données
ou le respect du droit d'auteur vous
avez des interlocuteurs changeants
pas à plein temps et qui donc pour moi
ça c'est pas uniquement il y a un petit
peu une entreprise qui croit très vite
et qui peut subir des crises de
croissance mais mais ça va au-delà de ça
puisque la maîtrise marketing et la
maîtrise de leur moteur de recherche
montre que c'est sur certains sujets qui
leur paraissent importants ils sont
parfaitement organisés
une petite précision technique question
de béotien mais
dans les programmes diffusés ce sont des
programmes essentiellement extérieurs
certaines ces programmes proviennent de
créateurs d'influenceurs quelle est la
responsabilité de ces gens qui
produisent les programmes au regard des
droits d'auteur à ce qui était à la fois
morales et économique est-ce que tout
doit transister par la plateforme ou
est-ce que ces personnes quand elles
recourt une musique ou à des images que
vous pouviez vous pourriez si vous aviez
le bénéfice d'accès à la base de données
identifiées comme des des
œuvres protégées par votre société
d'auteur comment ça se passe qui est
responsable il y a une double
responsabilité est-ce que on peut aussi
essayer de s'en prendre au créateurs
eux-mêmes
non les créateurs ils mettent leurs
œuvres à disposition sur YouTube sur Tik
Tok et en général ils ont un partage de
recettes publicitaires enfin ça c'est ce
sont des créations des créations
originales d'ailleurs à la SACD on a mis
en place et c'était à l'époque avec
leur partenariat avec YouTube et Google
deux studios d'enregistrement pour
qu'ils puissent enregistrer
des vidéos et d'ailleurs si vous avez le
temps je vous invite à venir visiter
les locaux c'est c'est assez intéressant
le sujet c'est que on il y a certains
comptes de Tik Tok
qui reprennent des vidéos de de
youtubeurs ou de tiktokers et ce qui est
très intéressant c'est que quand celui
qui a créé l'oeuvre veut faire retirer
les
œuvres qui ont été mises de façon
illicite et qui ne sont pas sur ce qu'on
s'en compte donc il lui rapporte rien il
n'y arrive pas parce qu'on lui dit c'est
pas vous l'auteur le créateur non c'est
l'autre donc il y a tout un sujet de de
relation parce qu'il y a certains qui
sont qui se sont spécialisés dans le
pillage des oeuvres des créateurs qui
s'attribuent les droits et c'est très
compliqué pour l'auteur original
véritable auteur de se faire reconnaître
et de faire retirer ce qui est illicite
c'est à lui quand il le met sur son
compte qu'on dit qu'il est illicite
voilà donc il y a pas tous ces outils
assez performants que par exemple le
YouTube a mis en place pour faire
respecter les hommes moi j'ai eu de
temps en temps des appels de cinéaste
même très connu qui avait des oeuvres
diffusées sur Youtube
en l'espace de une heure c'était retiré
donc ça allait
extrêmement vite parce que mais si
c'était sur Youtube c'est aussi que
et le producteur n'avait pas fait
l'effort de faire protéger l'oeuvre
parce que si vous faites le marquage ça
ne rentre pas dans le système et la
meilleure manière de se protéger c'est
justement de mettre en place des
dispositifs qui permettent d'éviter à
particulier
de prendre une vidéo et et de la
diffuser et de la disséminer sur
Internet parce que à ce moment-là la
piraterie va extrêmement vite
de Tik Tok de cette de ne pas être doté
d'un c'est pas forcément à Eddy canton
c'est le système de youtube il peut y en
avoir d'autres tout aussi performants et
TikTok a choisi de d'avoir la taille et
la puissance qu'il a aujourd'hui sans du
tout développer et mettre en place un
outil technique de ce type là
juste une petite précision
vous nous disiez tout à l'heure je suis
directeur général que Tik Tok ne
participait pas au financement du CNC
est-ce que ce financement du CNC il est
facultatif et après tout ils ont le
droit de faire ce qu'ils veulent ou
est-ce que Tik Tok en tant que
plateforme en tant que
oui en tant que plateforme est
théoriquement tenu de participer à ce
financement et par conséquent serait
dans l'illégalité si elles ne le font
pas monsieur le rapporteur heureusement
qu'il est obligatoire sinon ne comptez
pas sur la générosité des chaînes de
télévision même française ou des
plateformes et ça a été voté par le par
le Parlement français voilà c'est c'est
tout le système de financement de la
création audiovisuel et du cinéma en
France qui fait que les diffuseurs ont
une taxation qui va au Centre national
du cinéma est diffuseurs y compris les
salles de cinéma d'ailleurs et qui
ensuite est redistribué à la fois pour
les salles pour les moderniser c'est
pour ça qu'on a un parc de ça
l'extrêmement moderne et performant en
France vers la distribution des films
qui est une activité difficile et très
risquée et vers la production et le
meilleur exemple c'est quand le
Parlement a voté la taxe qu'on a appelé
taxe youtube avec un financement du du
CNC pour le CNC en contrepartie le CNC a
créé un fonds de soutien pour les
youtubeurs et ça permet d'intégrer ces
jeunes créateurs dans un environnement
régulé qui est celui de notre système
audiovisuel et cinématographique en
France c'est un système unique au monde
par les moyens de redistribution ce qui
fait que le développement la récent des
plateformes qui ont bénéficié du covid
parce que pendant la période covid
évidemment le spectacle vivant a été
fermé les salles de cinéma étaient
fermées je n'insiste pas on a perdu de
très peu au Conseil d'État mais bon
on a perdu alors qu'on a gagné en
Belgique d'ailleurs c'était le même
virus à mon avis mais c'était pas les
mêmes juges donc
et donc ce système extrêmement
performant qui fait qu'on a et on peut
le dire après les États-Unis le deuxième
cinéma du monde et un audiovisuel qui
s'est développé les plateformes et leur
arrivée l'intégration des plateformes en
France a été réalisé d'une part par le
financement par le CNC et d'autre part
par la directive SMA qui nous permet de
soumettre à des obligations
d'investissement le chiffre d'affaires
de ces plateformes réalisées en France
alors que précédemment on ne pouvait pas
le faire parce que la directive disait
on applique la loi du pays d'origine et
comme par hasard les plateformes
s'installent où
dans le pays où il y a le moins d'impôts
il y en a plusieurs en Europe et dans
les pays où il y a le moins
d'obligations culturelles voilà et ça a
été grâce à des terminations du gouver
en français qu'on a pu faire cette
directive SMAT parce que Bruxelles a
compris qu'ils étaient incapables de
mettre à l'échelon européen une règle
unique un taux en quelque sorte unique
de contribution et je dois dire que dans
la transposition de la directive ça
allait décrets d'application la France
est nettement au-dessus en matière
d'obligation des autres pays on est
trois ou quatre fois on a des niveaux
d'obligation d'investissement trois ou
quatre fois supérieur à ceux des autres
pays européens
et donc vous nous confirmez d'une part
que Tik Tok parce qu'on pourrait penser
qu'en raison de la
du caractère récent de leur de leur
nombre d'utilisateurs ils n'ont pas
jusqu'à présent été concernés par cette
loi vous nous confirmez qu'ils sont bien
concernés et qu'ils doivent cette taxe
et vous nous confirmez d'autre part
qu'il ne la paye pas
je sais pas
on s'est engagé à un tire je sais plus
quelle formule vous avez dit au début et
toute la vérité on peut vous dire ce
qu'on pense mais on ne sait pas c'est
seul la direction générale des finances
publiques de notre point de vue après
avoir lu la loi qui porte qui crée cette
taxe on nous on considère que Tik Tok y
est assujetti comme comme YouTube comme
meta et comme d'autres et on entend dire
qu'à ce stade
ce serait pas à quitter mais c'est ni
c'est à Tik Tok et à l'administration
fiscale de au dire ce qu'il en est de
cette question
vous passez un coup de fil au Centre
national du cinéma cet après-midi je
pense qu'il vous répondront tout de
suite pour savoir si la taxe est
acquitée ou n'est pas a quitté mais je
ne vois pas parce qu'en fait ils sont
concurrents ce serait complètement
illogique YouTube paie une taxe et que
Tik Tok ne la paye pas alors que
[Musique]
non pour la taxe CNC je pense que la
réponse la plus rapide viendra du CNC
mais nous on a un indice c'est que le
c'est comme Pascal le disait tout à
l'heure dès lors que la taxe a été votée
et payé par YouTube le CNC a mis en
place un fond de soutien pour aider les
créateurs sur Youtube on a constaté que
les dépenses sur ce fond de soutien sont
suivis à peu près la croissance du
chiffre d'affaires de YouTube
et il y a pas de fonds soutien Tik Tok
si on a fait le tour pour autant que on
puisse nous vous remercions de votre
présence et de la précision de vos
réponses merci beaucoup merci et j'ai ce
document pour vous le constat de
l'alparé c'était différent nous prenons
merci